okay so I will be the first one to admit
that when it comes to Wonder Woman
before the new 52 I am by no means an
expert in her character I have read some
stories here and there but she's just
like a person out there that's like been
around for a long time and she's really
strong a Hindu stuff but I was like
never knowledgeable about her character
and honestly I never really had a reason
to be like Wonder Woman had never really
interested me before that was until I
talked to you guys anyway so I'm hanging
out in the discord chat one day and I'm
talking to all you guys you know a bunch
of fans of the weekly poll and then I
was like man like I need to do Wonder
Woman stories but I've already covered
like Wonder Woman rebirth like the first
two arcs the lies and year one like what
are some good Wonder Woman stories that
I can do and people are like doohickeys
heya and I'm like what's the good hey
they're like that's the story where
Wonder Woman beats the hell out of
Batman and I'm like what and so I fired
it up like I grabbed the comic and just
started reading through it oh my god
this comic is so good this story is
amazing it is there's almost
mind-blowing crazily enough it's written
by greg rucka the guy who's writing
Wonder Woman rebirth right now so I can
see where he's just been like one of the
most influential Wonder Woman writers
you know since like forever but um but
hey Katya is is beautiful because it
focuses so much on like the character of
Wonder Woman like what she's about um
it's it's let's get into this you guys
can see what I'm talking about
so the cool thing here is that what what
happens is greg rucka basically this
kind of opens up with giving us an idea
of what hickety is and hickety is a
tradition that stretches all the way
back to you know the old old ages you
know the early ages of like the Greek
and Roman empires I mean it's really
just one of these extremely old rituals
it's almost as old as society itself but
the process of Hecate a-- involves a
person basically you know going through
and basing themselves to someone else
you know in this instance it is
basically a guy who's more or less poor
who's being you know demonized or
whatever the case may be a basing
himself to another man this guy in turn
provides a home for this poor man he
provides food for this poor man there
are rules there are regulations that
have to be followed according to the
laws of Hecate now when I say a basing I
simply mean the idea that he basically
supplants himself he says look you know
I am someone who is I'm just not worthy
I'm
I'm the lowest form of life possible you
know I will exist in service to you but
it doesn't mean that the person that you
know basically has control here so they
can do anything they want to you know
there has to be decorum there has to be
appropriate attitudes appropriate
tendencies those individuals who abuse
the ritual whether it's the person who
is abasing themself or the person who is
basically taking care of this poor guy
in this instance if either one of them
abuse it the furies will come for them
now the Furies are and I can remember
exactly how it is that their name is
pronounced I've been calling them what
does that Aron eyes but I don't think I
don't think Aaron eyes was right but
Furies is another another term that they
use here but essentially the Furies are
basically like these vengeful beings
that arrive when someone makes a false
promise which is to say yes I promise I
will do this and then they don't in the
case of picket and if somebody comes to
you and they have based themselves and
you accept Hecate a-- and then break
your promise the theories will find you
and they will kill you and that's
exactly what happens in this ancient
story that were given is that again but
this wealthy man basically agrees to hit
qatayef or this poor man but when he's
supposed to be abiding by these rules
and these rituals ah this what a man
lashes out he screams of the poor man
attacks the poor man different things
like that and in response you know after
he basically murders him the Furies come
for him and basically kill him and
that's what Wonder Woman's really
talking about here she's talking about
the nature of hickety and so what we do
is we wind back to about three weeks ago
now there's not going to be any time
travel here I mean really the beginning
of the story takes place in the modern
day with the exception of just you know
that really old legend okay it's half
the rest of the story takes place you
know three weeks ago or over the course
of three weeks or you know some along
those lines but what we do is we
actually pick up with a with a woman and
what we end up finding out is that this
woman is basically being caught up to by
Batman after having committed a murder
now of course as we would expect with
Batman in any comic book he does not
allow laws you know to be broken he
punishes all individuals for the laws
they break regardless of what that law
happens to be noble I won't say it's
that extreme like he's not going to
swoop in and like carry you to jail for
jaywalking but in certainly a situation
like murder that person has to be held
accountable now notice in this story
we're not being given the original
explanation of why this happens all
we're being told is that this girl
Danielle basically murders a man and
that's it now of course in the
confrontation with Batman
she's basically able to make her escape
after jumping off a bridge and so you
know for the time being you know Batman
most likely knows is she's very much
alive but Batman's got other fish to fry
he's got other things to worry about and
so for the most part he just kind of
fades into the background so what we do
is we follow Wonder Woman in her almost
everyday life we don't see every
instance of it but it's one of the cool
things because remember when it comes to
like these original graphic novels when
it comes to be standalone stories these
are usually designed to both introduce
people to what characters are about as
well as give us an idea of you know who
these characters are on a personal level
and one of the things one of the major
aspects of Wonder Woman's character has
always been both how she's physically
designed which is to say the beauty that
she's depicted as having in the comics
as well as the fact that she's such a
powerful and prominent hero and so
because of this she has really gained
the adoration of society almost at large
she shows up in a place and people flock
to get her autograph
sometimes as young girls who feel
empowered by Wonder Woman sometimes it's
men who feel empowered in different ways
by Wonder Woman but the fact remains
here that she does have a massive effect
on society as a whole and that's one of
the big things is kind of important with
this story is because this is one of
those stories of DC Road where really
highlights like the hope of comic book
characters the great aspect of comic
book characters is very similar to like
Paul Dini and Alex Ross when they wrote
world's greatest superheroes which if
you never read that you guys really need
to read that I mean it looks beautiful
the Wonder Woman story is absolutely
gorgeous I mean it's it's every single
panel every single page and that comic
could be a poster I mean it's just it's
Alex Ross art it's just absolutely
gorgeous but of course Daniel catches up
to Wonder Woman and when she does she
pledges Hecate now here is the way that
this works was Danielle approaching
Wonder Woman and pledging hey Katia
she's doing it without Wonder Woman
knowing anything about her past
Wonder Woman doesn't know where she's
coming from she doesn't know what she is
Wonder Woman is abiding by the honor the
the time-honored tradition that if a
person comes to you and pledges to CATIA
that you in turn have to say yes and the
only way the hickety eval can be broken
is it the person pledging it lets it go
if they release you know that individual
from their service so in this
circumstance Daniel shows up and as far
as Wonder Woman knows she's genuinely
pledging Higa taya and so Wonder Woman
of course is obliged to accept and
that's the
reason why with regards to this story
that the only way for Danielle to be to
basically release Wonder Woman from the
baltica taya is for Danielle to actually
do it on her own it's the only way for
Wonder willing to be able to walk away
and to be able to be released from this
particular valve now one of the things
that we're not given by greg rucka is
how long this goes on for in the sense
that maybe it's permanent maybe a person
will forever be held to the vow of a
catana but more often than not it seems
like it's only ever temporary it's a
very short amount of thing and so if a
very poor person showed up to a very
rich person and basically vowed hikky
taya the rich person could take them in
and basically go to the process of
helping that poor person get up to their
feet maybe even make some money on their
own after which the poor person would be
obliged to let the rich person go and
that's what Wonder Woman says with this
whole process of hikky taya being
accepted by Wonder Woman what she does
is she gives us rules
she gives us guidelines she gives us a
code that has to be followed whenever
hickety it is accepted now of course
Wonder Woman also begins to realize
what's going on with regards to the
Furies watching the events unfold and so
on and so forth but we learn a little
bit more about them here in a second
what Wonder Woman tells us is that when
uh when a valve Hecate is accepted that
comfort must be given to the supplicant
the person that shows up in this
instance danielle has to feel comforted
which is to say Q has to be given food
she has to be served at a table she
can't be made to live in destitution and
squalor
Wonder Woman couldn't force her to live
inside of a cabinet or something like
that that would violate the vow of a
hickie taya and the Furies would come
after her there has to be basically
recognizing the honor of the person that
comes and vows makes a hickety a vow in
this instance recognizing that
essentially Daniels showing up
whether--whether had their hand asking
for help from Wonder Woman and in turn
Wonder Woman is saying yes and she
cannot abuse that fact however Daniel
herself has to abide by rules that she
basically cannot abuse the offering of
Wonder Woman were just to say she can't
eat her out of house and home
she can't spend all of her money she
can't mistreat Wonder Woman in any form
or fashion she can't talk down to her
she can't make her feel as though she's
not nearly as important Daniel has to
realize that at any point
Wonder Woman could have said no if she
so felt like it if she believed that
Danielle was making a hickety a vow
under false pretenses now this is really
kind of a cool thing this is really a
really awesome concept by greg rucka and
the Rees
why it's because of the fact that what
it does is it hits home to the nature of
Wonder Woman Wonder Woman has always
been this character that's very loyal
this character that's very warrior
minded this character that would go to
the ends of the earth for the members of
her team and would even fight against
the Justice League if it was necessary
in order to achieve a certain goal that
was one of the things that was fleshed
out during tower battle right I mean
like there was this whole circumstance
where Batman was talking about how the
only way to beat Wonder Woman is to
basically make her fight until she's
physically exhausted and her body shuts
down because she will never give up and
so because of this the Wonder Woman
basically appears to the Furies and says
look this girl Dani is under my
protection we've sworn of Alpha Kataya
you have to leave now of course what the
Furies do is they basically taught
Wonder Woman a bit and it's also Greg
Rucka giving us an understanding of
where the Furies reside which is to say
that Wonder Woman is very strong she's
very capable she's every bit as powerful
as Superman if not a little bit better
in terms of her fighting prowess and the
limits that show go to to win but at the
end of the day the Furies are
effectively these immortal goddesses of
vengeance they can't be destroyed by
conventional means and Wonder Woman
couldn't certainly beat him to death and
so because of that they are in every bit
more powerful than she is and they make
this presence known by saying do you
really want us to kill you because we
can or we can just let this valve Hecate
up run its course and as long as you
abide by the laws as you're supposed to
then everything will be fine and so
because of this we basically pick up the
following morning now this again is kind
of the cool aspect of Wonder Woman
because with her character she was
always sort of this character that fell
in line with like Batman Superman and a
myriad of other characters and what I
mean by that is one of the big
differences between Marvel and DC when
it comes to superheroes is that we don't
really have like the normal everyday
goings-on of Marvel comic book
characters which is to say we don't
usually see Tony Stark in like board
meetings we don't usually see Tony Stark
doing whatever is it he does on a day to
day whenever he's running his business
we don't really see those kinds of
things but we do see Clark Kent as a
news reporter we do see Bruce Wayne you
know when he's basically the guy who's
being a philanthropist and we certainly
see Wonder Woman when she's going about
her regular goals as being an ambassador
for Thinnes Kira meeting with the United
Nations and meeting with pharmaceutical
companies I'm trying to make sure that
medicine gets to the places that it
needs to go these are the kind of things
that she does and so of course with
Daniel having sworn about hikky Talia
through basically has to do it
Wonder Woman wants her to do in terms of
being her assistant she's got to take
notes you got to take dictation
different things like that but again
this vows still remains now the cool
thing is that it does give Danielle a
chance to see what Wonder Woman is about
that she's more than just a hero that
runs around fights alongside the Justice
League beating up monsters and at the
end of that there's a lot more to her
than that she's every bit humanitarian
she fights for the right thing no matter
what it might happen to be she's always
there to lend a helping hand to those
individuals who need her and that is the
important element of wonder one really
more so important than even this story
itself is that Wonder Woman inherently
has always been this superhero that had
to kind of arrive on the scene and carve
a niche for herself in the sense of just
empowering young women who read her
comics you know empowering young people
who felt disenfranchised who happened to
stumble across her comics she always had
to fall in line with Superman with
Batman you know with the Teen Titans
she's one of a litany of superheroes who
serves the purpose of empowering people
who can relate to her and so that's one
of the coolest things about Wonder Woman
you know as a concept you know she's
almost consistently underrated in terms
of what it is that she's capable of
nobody sits down and says man if there's
anybody I want to have in my corner in
this fight it's Wonder Woman no they say
I want Superman I want that man I want
80 of the other members in the Justice
League except for her but the cool thing
is that when it comes down to it she's
actually the one you want like she's
really the one you want your corner
because she'll fight until the bitter
end and that is the point that Greg
Rucka makes when Batman shows up on her
doorstep when Batman arrives and says
look you know you are harboring a
fugitive
this girl Danielle is a murderer and I'm
here to take her back to prison now
under normal circumstances wonder one
would be like oh ho I didn't know that
we're here you go take her you know take
her off to prison do what everyone do I
mean I don't care
but Wonder Woman has sworn about you
know Danielle is under her protection
and there's more here than just the idea
of well the Furies might get me so I
have to keep her protected it's an honor
bound thing that's the difference here
that's really that kind of the core of
the story if Danny had a first Wonder
Woman and if Danny had said look I made
some terrible decisions if you ask me I
will explain them to you but at this
moment I need your protection even if
there was no valve hikky taya Wonder
Woman would still keep her protected she
would still keep it protected from
Batman and it's not because he's just
like oh Batman's oh man
when I beat him no it's an honor thing
she swore an oath to this woman even if
the even if the oath is only as
significant as Wonder Woman allows it to
be she would it was still an oath that
she swore now again because this is the
guitar there are mortal consequences for
Wonder Woman falling short of her
agreement but the fact remains here it's
basically Greg Rucka hitting on the idea
that if Wonder Woman makes a promise she
will keep it no matter what happens now
of course what we also end up finding
out here is that the reasons for
Danielle engaging in these acts of
murder actually served a purpose when
that man comes busting in he starts
running off names like Artie Mason of
Steve Rittenhouse Peter Collins so on
and so forth these different guys Roy
Braddock these different guys that she
had basically killed now at the end of
the day Wonder Woman still says no you
cannot take this girl and this fight
between herself and Batman ends quick
fast and in a hurry I mean there isn't
there is not much to be had here you
know Batman kind of comes busting in
look this girl's coming with me
Wonder Woman grabs in and throws him out
of window and that's it I mean Batman
you know don't fight again later on but
he gets rekt pretty easily and so
ultimately you know one woman says look
you can leave with your life or you can
stay and die and so ultimately Batman
decides to leave with his life now as we
know it's not over
Batman is going to make his return the
two of them are going to fight again
but from here we get into this whole
discussion about what it is that
Danielle had done and what we find out
is that Danielle had a younger sister
and her younger sister had basically
arrived in Gotham City not realizing
what she was getting into she had a bus
to get paid for her by Roy Braddock and
of course where Braddock had basically
brought her in and then began saying
things like you owe me for the ticket
that I bought you which began as a very
well not really a pretty innocent thing
but it led to her basically being forced
to make concessions you know she was
basically taking pictures of she wasn't
comfortable with pictures eventually led
to movies movies led to her being
uncomfortable what she was doing she
started to fight back she was basically
forced into drugs which in turn led to
her being involved in prostitution and
so her life just took this downward
spiral falling into absolute hell but
the reason why this girl was preyed upon
so easily was because of the fact that
she was from Heartland America
she was from Missouri she's this young
innocent girl that has no ideas of the
ways of the world and when she got to
the big city the big city ate her right
up and so because of this this girl was
basically killed now in response to this
you know when she died of a drug
this eventually led to Danielle arriving
on the scene and wreaking absolute havoc
I mean she got revenge like you wouldn't
believe stabbed in the death or shot him
or whatever the case may be but in her
mind those men had to die and so because
of that Wonder Woman
well I wouldn't necessarily say she
accepts the story she understands where
Danielle's coming from you know Wonder
Woman thinks people who were basically
her equals you know cassie sandsmark she
thinks of like Donna Troy people who are
every bit sisters so to speak to Wonder
Woman people she confides in people that
she talks to people that she trusts
implicitly what if something like that
had happened to them and so Wonder Woman
understands where Daniels coming from
and she more or less basically makes a
statement if the shoe were on the other
foot
if I were in Danielle's position I would
have done the exact same thing and
that's what makes the story so disarray
when I was reading through this segment
you know where we were basically being
told all the terrible experiences that a
bit of a fallen the sister of Danielle
you know how she had been basically made
to engage in some act that she wasn't
really comfortable with I could imagine
the rage you know the Danielle would
feel only to find out that her sister
had experienced as hell and then turned
around and died being coursing through a
life that she didn't want to be a part
of and so you know ultimately this
basically leads to the Furies arriving
on the doorstep you know of Wonder Woman
and basically saying look the battle
tickets hey it is almost finished I'm
begin talking about things like water
pipes so on and so forth which
ultimately leads Wonder Woman to an
aqueduct they switch to the docks of
Gotham City and this is really where the
fight begins to come to a head and the
reason is because of the fact that
Danielle after having basically taken
off over her gills without you know
putting one woman in the situation
eventually runs into Batman again now of
course with Batman continuing to chase
after Danielle this is when Wonder Woman
steps in and this is when the real fight
breaks out the cool thing about Batman
as a character one of the things I like
about him the most is that he's very
similar to Wonder Woman in the sense
that he will just keep fighting he'll
just keep coming back and coming back
each time he'll learn
you know he'll fight Wonder Woman he'll
end up being you know defeated he'll
learn his lesson and he'll come back now
at this point Wonder Woman you know
learning lessons is more or less like a
zero sum right like skis he knows
everything there is to know about Wonder
Woman it's so really you know in some
part of his mind he would have to know
that being here is a fool's errand you
know if Wonder Woman says look this girl
is under my protection you cannot harm
her and she's adamant about it Batman
would have to legitimately believe that
Wonder Woman is going to protect us
no matter what even if it means killing
Bruce Wayne himself and that's really
what it is the Greg Luck is presenting
here he's presenting us a scenario where
you have an unstoppable force meeting an
immovable object Batman's desire to hold
those who commit crimes accountable for
their actions is unshakable I mean that
does not go away that is the core of who
he is but Wonder Woman's honor when she
makes a promise that she keeps it that
is just as unshakable and so it's almost
like you just have two people smashing
their heads against each other one of
them is going to have to give and it
ain't going to be Wonder Woman and so of
course what this does is it leads to a
direct battle between the two and Batman
is immediately overpowered no ifs ands
or buts now following this Batman
actually tries to invoke hikky taya and
that's kind of the funny thing is he
says look you know I supplant myself
before you that kind of think Wonder
Woman immediately turns them down
because she says look you're not making
this vow because you genuinely mean it
because you really want my protection
you're doing this because of the fact
that you believe that it's going to
basically give you the ability to take
Daniel away now of course one of the
things that I'm not too partial on with
this is it almost seems as though Greg
Rucka is kind of toning down how smart
Batman is and ensures a lot of writers
will do that I mean if that were
consistently shown to be as smart as he
is whenever we see the most extreme
demonstrations of his intelligence then
he would solve every problem everywhere
all the time there has to be instances
when Batman's intelligence is toned down
simply for the sake of storytelling in
this instance where one woman says look
you know you have to know if you know he
could tell you like you believe you do
you have to know that I can say no if I
believe that you don't really mean it
and of course you know this is basically
her saying you do not know Higa taya as
well as you think you do you know you
are not well-versed in the history of
this particular vow now we would have to
believe that in the first encounter when
Wonder Woman said look I swore a vow of
Higa taya to Danielle you know she's
under my protection
I cannot let her go even if Batman had
to go back and do research
he would have researched every scrap and
iota of information so maybe it's just
that he missed something but I have a
hard time believing that he wouldn't
have a full understanding of the valve
hikky taya as it related to like
Achilles one of the most notable
characters in Greek mythology and so
because of that with her basically
overpowering Batman and was Danielle
realizing she's the only way for the vow
to be broken
Danielle effectively jumps off the top
of the
water tower and kills herself it's
basically her saying look you know I put
you in the situation the only way for
you to get out is for me to basically
let myself go and that's it she just
sacrifices her own life in the process
and so what this does is it leaves
Wonder Woman kind of battered and broken
to a degree I mean she's really just
kind of crushed because on a personal
level she feels like she's failed you
know she feels like she hasn't done her
job the way that she's supposed to
Danielle was under her protection
it was Wonder Woman's job to keep
Danielle safe even if it meant keeping
Danielle safe from herself but as the
story begins to line down what a woman's
just kind of left with her thoughts of
course the Furies began to more let's go
away and that's really the end of that
but Wonder Woman is just kind of left to
realize you know that this life that she
lives you know this life out here in the
world is not nearly as easy as she
thought it was going to be there are
constant struggles constant ordeals the
different mythological beings are
constantly coming home to roost and so
as she continues to kind of deal with
this concept she always has to straddle
you know both sides always has to
recognize it at the end of the day she's
always going to have a hard time trying
to have the best of both worlds so to
speak but we're not being said guys if
you are new here to come this explain
make sure you guys to the sub button to
become part of the Robin Corps if you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and I will catch you all on
earth peace
[Music]